by the one thing that I care most about
right and if you're not active if I'm
not acting and I don't have one thing
that I care most about my wife hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my flash episode 21 video obviously it
was a big Katee Sackhoff episode
you probably detected all the track that
they were laying for the lead up into
the finale in Marley's helping team
flash out like the finale is a
mysterious person helping team flash
fight to bow that mysterious person is
Marley's along with coffee shop girl but
mostly a lot of these moments especially
the Harrison wells storyline was teeing
up that Marley's twist we got to see a
couple different versions of the Council
of Wells and I think we saw a little bit
from the human race comic book storyline
so if your big comic book reader I think
they are pulling some things from that
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos we're heading into the flash
finale we're gonna be talking about
season 5 stuff pretty soon I'm expecting
to get the pay off for a coffee girl
like the final explainer for what her
name's gonna be in which versions of
comic book speedsters they combine to
create her character but number 10
welcome back reporter iris berry wakes
up at 5 in the morning she's been up all
night trying to collate information for
an article that she's writing remember
earlier this season they teed up the
idea that she was firing up the blog
again it's just the path to her becoming
an award-winning journalist writing
about the Flash's adventures that will
become a big part of the flash Museum in
the future that they might try to bring
back around via coffee girl like the
whole idea of iris writing stories about
the flash is that those stories survive
into the future people from the future
read them and it inspires them to do
good things to do bad things in the case
of the reverse-flash so just remember
that for every fanboy of the flash there
is like a crazy fanboy a la Barthe on
that read about the adventures of the
flash it go crazy off the rail so there
are a number of reasons why it's
important that iris write stories about
the flash and this is just the beginning
of that number 9 Welcome Back council of
wells I wasn't a huge fan of all the
characters so I am happy that they're
kind of brushing past this I love the
concept of the Council of wells you get
Tom Cavanaugh doing a bunch of different
versions of the characters to varying
effects some of them are funnier than
others some of them are kind of annoying
Andrew Dice
clay was probably my favorite new one so
I should say number eight the Council of
rejects I didn't catch which earth HP
Wells the one who wrote the poetry about
bread was from I'm gonna have to rewatch
the episode with subtitles when they
post it I'm making this video like hours
and hours before they posted online so
there aren't any subtitles available but
I think he's just a spin on HP Lovecraft
if HP Lovecraft spoke with a weird
French accent it wrote really bad poetry
about bread Sonny wells from earth-2 NT
for is Andrew Dice Clay if you don't
know who he is he's this big comedian
from the 80s he had this very specific
look in a very specific New Jersey
accent the Tom Cavanagh is pulling off
pretty watts it's a pretty good
impression birth 24 in the comics is
ruled by what they called the American
military entertainment complex it
becomes them protecting what they call
the American Empire against outside
interests and obviously you're familiar
with Matthew McConaughey wells he's a
carryover from the Council of wells
they're calling this the Council of
Harrisons but the whole idea is is that
Harry and Harrison's title is a play on
Harry and the Hendersons I wasn't
expecting any Grodd but I was like well
that's a story about Bigfoot maybe
they're just using that because it
sounds funny and based on the plot of
the episode that seems like the case but
they give him the idea to search teuvos
feelings to try and figure out what's
going on with him but number 7 Caitlyn
slowly going mad trying to get killer
frost back
I was wondering how crazy they would
write her like how far would she go
before team flash found out what she was
trying to do and thankfully they didn't
stretch it out too long like they did
during season 3 I think there were a
couple plot twists in the name of
getting through that as fast as possible
like they're not doing that thing where
team flash lies to each other a whole
lot which I think people got really
frustrated with during season 3 but the
whole idea has predicted is that she's
gonna do whatever it takes to get killer
frost back and there were a couple key
lines of dialogue from Amunet black to
give us an idea for where they might
take the character during season 5
number 6 Caitlyn making that secret deal
on the sly with Amunet this sort of
their accelerated version of Caitlyn
keeping the shard of the philosopher's
stone during season 3 in that leading to
that big killer frost breakout it
provides the intro for Amunet wearing
that horrible costume speaking with a
southern accent
running the
illegal gambling operation if you're big
Katee Sackhoff fan you may have
recognized the accent that she was doing
but if you don't watch a lot of her
other non battlestar stuff she was on a
show called Longmire where she spoke
with something of a southern accent
that's kind of what I felt like she was
going for when they first found her like
this was meant to be a fake accent
because she's supposed to have a British
accent naturally so I think I've said
many times that I'm not a big fan of the
British accent the Katee Sackhoff does
further the normal Amunet black
character but I actually did like the
southern accent that she did there are
certain things about the character that
I like but for the most part I don't
like what the show has done with her and
I think this is the last episode that
she's gonna be in this season one of the
funnier moments though was when she
called out Barry for his weak disguise
so it's a long-standing trope of any
superhero story does they wear some
flimsy mask and nobody can tell that
it's them there were actually a couple
of series lately that have tried to
explain why it is that people can't tell
that it's them the explainer that the
Black Lightning TV show went for was the
idea that because he gives off
electricity it becomes so bright that
your eyes are drawn away from his face
so you're not thinking about what his
face looks like and it also kind of
blinds you a little bit the other
explainer that a lot of comic book
people give for characters like Superman
is is that there aren't a lot of people
that interact with Clark Kent and
Superman on a daily basis so they're not
thinking about one character when
they're with the other besides like Lois
Lane she's the exception because she
does interviews with Superman all the
time but she also sits across the desk
all day from Clark Kent and knows him
really well so like your average person
on the street doesn't know who Clark
Kent is or only reads his articles and
doesn't know what his face looks like so
they're mostly just thinking about
Superman and Clark Kent is completely
separate entities but number four Barry
versus Iris over the article on DeVoe in
a possible flash human race Easter Egg
so if you haven't read the human race
storyline is sort of a self-contained
Wally West story where Wally is forced
to race for the fate of the human race
against an alien made up of pure energy
this alien comes along and says we
needed to decide who the fastest person
in the universe is so he goes from world
to world making them pick their fastest
person and race against other people and
if they lose the race he destroys the
planet so the whole idea is that the
planet has to work together to help
Wally West defeat this villain so as
sort of what Iris was talking about with
Barry when she said that the city puts
their faith in you the flash now it's
your turn to put your faith in the city
the other minor Easter Egg for that too
is that the villain to that story sits
in a chair that floats just like the
thinker on the TV show so I think
they're just cherry-picking a couple
moments from that comic book storyline
but you can check it out if you want
number three though was Amunet revealing
the truth of killer frost like this
gives us an idea for what might happen
with her character during season five so
she says that I never did anything for
you it was you the whole time you're the
person that made killer frost come out
because if you don't remember Caitlin
says that during the break between
seasons last year she was having trouble
going back and forth between Caitlin and
killer frost she went to Amunet to help
stabilize that she claims that she had a
device that did that but then Amunet
tells her no no I didn't do anything
that was you that was doing it this
killer frost in you has been with you
the whole time you've always been in
control whereas during season three
Caitlin felt like she was fighting her
like it was the Hulk versus banner and
Caitlin was always worried about her
Hulk controlling her but based on this
explanation she's been in control the
whole time and I think that will lead to
a more balanced version of killer frost
the Caitlin has an easier time
controlling like all season long they've
had to scare her into killer frost
I think season 5 comes along we see
killer frost again but it becomes more
of a conscious choice on Caitlin's part
like okay
killer frost powers activate but if you
look at her costume for next week's
episode they've already released the
episode 22 photos there's a picture of
her wearing these goggles it almost
looks like a killer frost twist on a
captain cold type of costume where she
wears the goggles but that's probably
because she's still wielding the gun
she hasn't fully got her powers back yet
so this might be an early version of
what her season 5 costume might end up
looking like because even if there are
only minor tweaks their costumes do
change from season to season like Barry
got a new costume in season 4 I wouldn't
be surprised if Caitlin got a new
costume to go with this new version of
killer frost that she's gonna bring back
but number 2 got team flash versus Noir
Faulk they take flash out just long
enough so that Amunet has to take
Norwalk out by himself but you get
better look at his venom ability we got
kind of a teaser for it during that
Bachelorette episode the first half of
the season it was always kind of unclear
what it was exactly that he did but he
gets buried with the gas he has to phase
it out of his body
if you don't remember the reverse-flash
did that exact same thing during season
one when they get him with the nanites
that are supposed to disable his access
to the Speed Force and he just kind of
vibrates the nanites out of his body but
the whole idea here is the idea that
someone as despicable as Amunet would
choose to help them out when faced with
the reality of Devo like they tell her
the truth and she says okay I'll help
you out even though she takes off at the
end if you're big Avatar fan you'll
probably like oh wow she's metalbending
herself away at the end of the episode I
think that was just a cool spin on the
idea of her comic book powers but
shout-out for Toph and she gives them
that special weapon the DeVoe is weak
against so they have to figure out how
to use that in number one Harrison wells
thanks to the Council of rejects figures
out that DeVoe hasn't been acting
because he lost the thing that he cares
about this is a very complex graph one
of the best jokes of the episode you
might not be able to understand these
complex smiley face emoji graphs that
I'm drawing here the whole idea
obviously being that they're gonna find
Marlies and try to appeal to her the
same way they tried to appeal to Amunet
so just all stuff setting up Marlies
versus DeVoe the big twist at the end
with everyone reacting positively to
irises article by crowdsourcing des
Vosges location so that he's not able to
hide is just like I said an easter egg
for the human race the city itself
helping Barry Allen solve a problem but
even though we didn't have a copy girl
scene in this episode they did go back
to jitters it was Caitlin and Joe and
Joe did give a specific call out to
fathering children so just the idea that
coffee girls related to them the whole
idea of the finale and the speedforce
symbols is that we get the final
explainer for that but I don't know if
they're gonna tee that up in next week's
episode but big shout out Diggle
actually helps them because if you've
seen the teaser for next week's episode
they go back to Argus and steal some of
that technology let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
and what kind of a killer frost do you
want to see next season given the idea
that Caitlin might have an easier time
controlling the transitions but what'll
happen is is I have a much more Marvel
opposed they just drop the Black Panther
blu-ray so there'll be a bunch
or black panther videos in between
everything leave your requests in the
comments below you know name a new flash
ring giveaway winner when I post my
flash trailer video tomorrow so click
here for my coffee girl finale video and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight